hi everyone since you seem to like the
last video we did like this I've invited
James back to talk about some more of
our physics degree horror stories so
these are some of our maybe least
favorite experiences from majoring in
physics so we did undergrad together but
honours and separate universities so
that's how last year of undergrad and
kind of the hardest year one of my
horror stories comes from my honours
year and it was our electromagnetism
exam and I always remember this exam
because it was a difficult course and we
were all quite stressed about the exam
the questions for from this book called
Jackson and we were anticipating it to
be really difficult but there was one
part of the exam that if one of the
class thought we might be able to pass
and that was this memorization test so
the lecturers had given us a sheet of
about 20 equations to memorize
beforehand and we knew that the first
two questions on the exam were going to
be asking us to regurgitate those
formula and we had to do it perfectly
like if you forgot a minus sign or a
symbol somewhere you got zero but this
seemed like the best way to get marks in
the exam so we all show up to the exam
we put away our books and we're just
sitting there waiting for it to start
but the lecturers don't show up and it
isn't until half an hour later that they
eventually turn up and in that half an
hour of waiting for them to come and
start the exam because everyone's so
worried about memorizing this formula
there's just sort of 30 people sitting
at their desks it's quietly chanting
like Maxwell's equations in its various
forms because we were all so stressed
about it but yeah that was one of the
funny sort of horrific experiences
ramona's my story comes from my honours
mid-year talk which is throughout honors
we have a year-long project that we do
on top of all of our coursework
and through the middle of the year we
basically talk about what our project is
and what we know about it what we plan
to do
so I had given a 15-minute talk on my
project which was related to crystal
field theory and we get to the questions
part where people from the audience just
start asking questions but if not a lot
of questions are being asked the person
hosting it who is one of the professor's
asks some questions just so you can
answer some questions to prove that you
know what you're doing and that you can
get some marks so I get asked a question
and then immediately someone from the
audience someone in my group starts
answering for me and at this point I
just don't really know what to do like
this is my question I'm supposed to
answer it to show them what I know and
he just immediately not giving me any
time to speak starts talking I'm just
sort of staring at him the person next
to him just always him sharply but he
kind of just ignores it he keeps on
talking and it was just not really a
horror story but just a weird experience
that left me kind of confused in front
of 30 people probably not what you want
when you're trying to answer your own
questions
yeah yeah yeah so those are how separate
stories but um I remember together and I
think it was second year again second
year physics also the wave is in optics
course from us that's the same guest
lecturer we spoke about last video we're
having a test and so we were like in a
tutorial room and we were all silently
working on our where it's an optics test
and then what everyone hopes for in a
test the fire alarm goes off and I don't
even happen before and I was like what
do we do this is like oh no and we all
got up and left the room and and when an
evacuated outside but no one really like
told us we should stay away from each
other everyone was like kind of talking
to each other but so immediately we had
30 physics students it's all clumping in
a circle like oh god what do you do oh
god are we allowed to talk yeah and like
it was actually quite a hot day so as
one question that like no one you had to
do we were all sort of like looking at
each other and no one wanted to say so
you know I know the answers but we're
all definitely fit the litter was
nowhere to be seen
I don't know
yeah but eventually we were like it was
a false alarm we were funneled back into
the room after quite a long time as well
and the liquor was just like know what
to do keep keep doing the test and we're
all just thinking should we bother
is this gonna even be counted it's gonna
be just thrown in the bin
yeah well like so it was a hard test
with a unusual turn to it my other story
comes from my third year talk I have a
lot of interesting stories with
presentations presentations we're in
third year we have a half yeah a
semester long project in which my own
was to build a laser and I was working
with a friend of ours the supervisor had
given us a gain medium which is what
gives the laser its color the gain
medium and question was an egg Adomian
doped silicon no it was phosphor glass
and we get to our talks my friend goes
first he starts talking all about
neodymium and the lasers specifically
what weird researched we want to make
sure when you about lasers themselves we
research in their demos as we found
neodymium YAG lasers which is yet trim
aluminium garnet so we were like oh yeah
neodymium YAG lasers these are great
we're going to talk all about our
neodymium YAG laser and then friend gets
to the end of this talk our supervisor
just sort of puts up his hand and says
hi yeah
so what lasers are using because I'm
pretty sure I gave you neodymium in
phosphor glass and
friend just sort of stands up there sick
and just aghast and immediately just
starts laughing like he has no idea what
to do it's obvious he's just completely
stuffed up yeah I was in the audience
for this talk and it's like we heard all
this great stuff about this laser which
is apparently not the laser you used and
he was just like oops meanwhile I'm in
the audience like okay I'm about to give
my talk I'm about to talk for ten
minutes about a laser I know it's not my
laser how can I sell but you know you
made the slides and you'd planned and
practiced the talk on your wrong laser
and at least at least you were second so
you had a heads up yes sir
I had all my slides already prepared I
was going through my talk like usual and
then at one point of my slides comes up
neodymium YAG lasers and I said
neodymium YAG lasers are the most common
type of neodymium laser however ours
neodymium in a phosphorous glass and I
was like nailed it saved it at the end
during the questions supervisor raises
hand and says hi yeah not a question but
you guys really like neodymium YAG don't
you and I didn't really have nose for
that I just sort of put they laughed
yeah I like that story I don't know if
the video is too long already but I'll
tell one more story and that's the case
of the missing assignment so this is
this is a story that is quite horrifying
for someone that it's not us our friend
but I was sort of involved as a
collateral in those stories so it
horrifies me he's still thinking about
it now so
and our friend couldn't come to uni on
this day that we had to hand in
assignments cuz he had to go to work so
he had stayed around uni the previous
evening written up this big assignment
that he'd spent quite a lot of effort on
written it up all nicely and then he
left it in the physics students room and
sent me a message saying hey Toby can
you hand in my assignment for me
tomorrow because I can't make it to the
class and I was like sure I'll pick it
up in the morning when I go in and I'll
hand it in at class time so I go there
in the morning and like I gotta pick up
an assignment looking around the room
and I can't find it in there and so I
sent a text that I knew would cause
widespread panic that was Tim saying
where exactly did you leave the
assignment and he was telling me where
exactly he left it and it wasn't there
and so he was getting panicked and he
asked me to look all around see does it
working the timings I asked me to look
in the recycling bin and the bins
outside that's like looking everywhere
for this assignment because I knew like
we had to hand the moon and I think
eventually what we guessed had happened
was the cleaners had come in throughout
the night or and early in the morning
and they pick up any loose paper that's
just like on a desk and a chair anywhere
around and they recycle it and take it
off with them so that assignment
apparently got recycled which was tragic
and I think he had to talk to the
lecturer and end up doing it all over
again which was pretty sad but um yeah
top tip from that story is don't leave
your assignments in reach of the
cleaners all right thanks James and I
hope you enjoyed listening to some of
those stories